[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book own your past change your future is
my co-host today as we answer questions
for folks about building wealth doing
work that they love and having actual
amazing
relationships
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ephraim is with us in atlanta to start
off this hour hey ephraim what's up
hey dave uh first off you what you've
done for me and my wife and our family's
just been incredible we've listened to
you we've read your books and uh
you've just been life-saving so thank
you for that well thank you actually you
did it i just told you what to do how
can i help
well
so
i've been married for about 30 years my
incredible wife we
are living in the house that we've
raised our girls in so we're at the
point now where we're empty nesters and
of course like a lot of people have
a house that we just it's it's too big
for our needs right now so with the
housing market being what it is i threw
out the ideas of my wife to consider
selling it and her point was well if we
sell high we got to buy high well she's
right about that with with going into
living in an apartment in an area that
we love it's a multi-use development
with retail with restaurants we're there
probably three or four not five days
a week and we love it there so i propose
that we get an apartment there for a
year to
enjoy living there and wait for the
housing market to come down and then be
ready when that time comes to build a
house or move into one or whatever
options we want to move forward with we
can
but she's i think it's a lot of
sentimental that she doesn't want to
sell the house
but the rental is about 4 000 a month
which we could easily afford
and
we would make
probably close to half a million dollars
on the house net
okay
so she her
her ultimatum was well call dave ramsey
and see what he has to say on it
so
oh i'm the tiebreaker yeah yes you will
i don't know if i can handle all this
responsibility a lot of pressure i got a
lot of pressure here
all right so let's uh let's change a
couple of um
a couple of the variables in the
conversation okay sure number one
i'll give you a 99
chance that the housing market is not
going down
okay
okay it has gone down two times in the
last 100 years
in the 1930s and in 2008 it's the only
time it's gone down
okay and then it snapped right back
almost instantaneously in the 2008. less
than a year
those how even the areas like for
instance las vegas was the worst hit by
the bubble burst it was overbuilt it was
the fastest growing city in america and
it was in it basically the bubble
exploded there and we saw values come
down pretty substantially
and uh
it was
18 months and they were all back
and then it's gone nowhere but north
since then so i don't predict housing is
going to go down at all in this turn in
this run round
uh my personal i do think it's going to
slow down its rate of increase
but that does defeat your premise okay
as far as renting until then so is there
a property in the
area you're talking about buying a condo
for instance that you guys could just
buy and move into
well we could okay hypothetically there
is actual properties around the area
you're talking about where you're not a
renter
yes it's obviously very very difficult
to find it you have to be ready to to
almost make a cash offer because it's it
doesn't it's not on the market long okay
okay so uh if you could pull that off it
changes the discussion i'm not going to
tell you to go rent
you're going to lose that argument
so she wins okay
uh okay because i think you're going to
end up going in the hole with a rental
amount and values are going to increase
albeit not at the rate they're currently
increasing
so you're gonna you're gonna lose money
two different ways by going to be a
renter i'm not opposed to you moving to
that area and moving into a less
expensive property in selling your
property and buying high and selling
high which is her point uh but buying
high and later buying higher after
having rented it and
no i'm not doing that one
usually
and dave you and sharon just did
something similar so you off live this
um eve from
normally i see couples have this
conversation
and it's all about the house and the
math
and this is a much bigger conversation
which is
this is we're we're sliding this into
phase three right we've had our time
together we've raised kids and we're
empty nesters and we built a
tremendous home together and a
tremendous life together
the next phase is what do we want this
next this next season to look like and
that it will include discussions about
home where we live and we want to go to
coffee shops and concerts we want to be
that couple we move out to the country
but that's a broader conversation that
as a part of that conversation will
involve grieving the the leaving the
house that you raised your kids in it's
got a lot of cool memories yeah and it
will what are your thoughts
without renting the house
renting it out
yes why do you want adventure rental
income
i'm just ready for change it's a it's a
5 000 square foot home
that just we
we live in a keeping room kitchen and
bedroom
yeah
okay
so i think that's the part you all need
to start talking about before we try to
do a real estate deal
i'm with john so the two of you need to
get aligned on what the future picture
is
of your life
and
what the future picture is okay it's a
smaller more efficient use of the re of
the square footage for you
uh for her what is the future picture
and then what is the thing that we can
do that has all of the future pictures
in common
yeah okay
um and uh and you know you're gonna give
up
some you know like if you have five
things i want your bottom two you might
not get
in terms of forced force ranking and she
has five things she might get her bottom
two and that's kind of what sharon and i
just went through honestly
um no we did a little bit of a similar
discussion and we had this huge house
and um it was a good time to get out of
a huge house and so it's kind of stage
two empty nester for us
um and uh
it was a good opportunity to cash in and
but we did immediately or simultaneously
buy another uh property half the size
that we moved into
uh as a temporary measure until someday
we build and uh
but uh uh but we had a lot of different
goals with that that we both aligned on
the future
now the deal is i think if you if you'll
start if the two of you will sit down
like john said and start working on a
future picture let's paint the picture
together what five years from now looks
like all right now what are the what has
to be true for us to get to that picture
then you're going to start making moves
that are going to cause you to sell this
house move downtown into a smaller condo
as a temporary move than later on build
or something like that you're going to
develop a game plan to
end up at the same place
and this can be a romantic fun
it's an exception
the word we kept using over and over is
this is a pain in the butt and it's an
adventure there you go we're signing up
for an adventure yeah and uh you know
moving is a pain renovating a household
moved in slightly was a pain with no
workers available
moving is a pain did i mention moving is
a pain it's the worst it's kind of like
having a root canal and you know but
it's an adventure because we and those
are the steps we took to get to where we
wanted to be
five years from today
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
open phones this hour
as we talk about building wealth doing
work that you love and creating actual
amazing relationships
dr john deloney is my co-host today he
is the number one national bestseller of
the new book own your past change your
future all about relationships and uh
dealing with mental wellness
uh and so for regular people that are
just trying to navigate this crazy world
we live in right now
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five it is event
week guys
orlando we will be seeing you for a sold
out
building wealth live event tomorrow
night may the 19th will be at calvary
orlando completely sold out over 3 300
tickets sold thank you guys we
appreciate you
and i can't wait it's going to be an
absolute blast we're going to walk you
through all the crazy stuff that's going
on out there in the financial world like
if you noticed your 401k turned into a
201k or something like that then we're
going to talk about it and the financial
principles that we teach we're going to
talk about all the you know just address
some of these issues head on and in a
logical wise way so you can leave with a
game plan where you'll know what to do
rachel cruz george campbell and i will
be doing that dr john deloney and ken
coleman will join us they'll be hosting
a free bonus session about work and
relationships to kick us off you don't
want to miss that those of you have
tickets be sure and plan on getting
there early look at that bonus early
session it's completely free and you do
want to be there for that it's pretty
incredible
um
work and relationships are a big deal
both right now
things are just tenuous out there so
this is us this is us helping you guys
on to the next level right
now if orlando completely sold out at 3
300 seats and if las vegas almost did
two weeks ago and was a complete uh
rousing rowdy fun crowd then you can
know that phoenix in september
sacramento minneapolis and san antonio
in november are going to be sold out
because they're already over half sold
out all of them tickets are only 25
and you can get a four pack of tickets
beginning at 60 bring your friends in
other words it's gonna be absolutely
amazing john i'm excited about this i
can't wait man it's fun we're gonna be
on the road for a week and i can't wait
to get out man the vegas uh
crowd was really cool the orlando crowd
is going to be cool it's going to be
great we're going to be staying over
because we start the entree leadership
summit starting on sunday
and we'll have about 3 000 folks there
as well 20 750 or so business leaders
from small business primarily all across
america and be doing about four days
there with jay leno uh nick saban
uh james clear from atomic habits uh our
team dr john and ken coleman and me will
be speaking and uh and on and on it just
uh a lot of the lineup is absolutely
incredible um wait a minute jocko not
james jocko is next year he shot goes
this year james clear is coming 20 23.
jonko is this year that's right i got it
backwards yeah and henry cloud will be
there this year and pat lincoln will be
there this year it's a world-class
leadership event uh one of the biggest
events we do of the year and looking
forward to that in orlando as well at
the grand hyatt and that of course is
sold out as well and it's usually sold
out like six months in advance so
uh tickets will go on sale for 2023
which will be in nashville for that
event very soon so really feels good to
be out there moving around seeing people
again i loved it in vegas was such a a
uh a great return because they they came
ready to party man yeah and it was loud
and they so many people showed up and
um by the way this little bonus session
the numbers they told us the other day
is they just finally quit counting
they're just like it's so full people so
many people are coming which is just
great that's good people are ready to
come on out and have a good time yeah
the bonus session may be bigger you
never know yeah
it's possible i love it so
it's just good times uh folks you know
those of you that have not um
you know have not begun your walk in
into the emotional healing from
everything that we've been through and
you're still
uh you're still living with a lot of
fear and hopelessness right now uh i
encourage you to get connected with
people again whether it's
whether it's at some kind of an event
like that i don't want to scare you
but uh the rest of us are out here and
uh we feel really good about hanging out
with other human beings yeah it's
important we need we need to be around
people right now
all right zach is going to be next up
he's in philadelphia hey zach welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
so i'm looking at a career change and i
wanted to get your input on this
but it's going to cost me
i work in law enforcement
and i'm in my eighth year
as a police officer
looking to change careers but kind of
don't want to lose that that pension
our department offers a military buy
buyback program
where
you the time served in the military you
have the option to buy that time back
towards your retirement
so my question for you is i'm at eight
years i can buy back four years to get
the minimum pension
to secure the minimum pension but it's
going to cost me 85 000
to do this
now i have the 85 000
in my 457 plan
and i can roll this over to the buyback
tax-free
no hit on it at all so i was wondering
if you think that is a good idea to do
okay almost all the buybacks that i've
ever done the numbers on
involve uh getting more money as a
result of having bought more years
and i i are you saying if you don't do
this you get zero
no what i'm saying is that for the
career change i'm looking at changing
careers you know i got that and you
leave and you don't want to you said i
don't want to lose my pension but the
truth is you're not going to lose your
pension you just want to enhance it with
this 85 000
no i will lose it so if i don't hit that
minimum threshold of 12 years
you can see right they would just cut me
a check yeah a woman no no no
they will cut you a check
for my pension contributions that i've
made correct so you just get your money
back no match no growth or anything like
that
it's correct it's yeah it's uh it's not
nearly as much as the pension would be
the pension would be 33 000
um for the rest of my life or they'll
cut me a check for like 25 000 one time
for my contributions
so i have the money in my in my 457 and
i can roll it over tax free um
so once you hit 12 years you get 33 you
qualify for the minimum pension and they
pay you every year every year for the
rest of your life starting now correct
no starting when i um when i would have
hit my 20th year so i still have to wait
eight years to start collecting it oh
ted gum is complicated okay
yeah
so it's a complicated financial formula
to figure out if it's smart
okay
because basically you got a 25 000 swing
one way
uh plus the eighty-five thousand
right right uh uh minus the eighty-five
thousand um uh
and then you got the eight-year wait and
you're not making listen the pension is
usually a horrible rate of return
usually around five or six percent
okay
um
what are you going to go do
uh well i just finished my four-year
degree um so i was looking at either
going federal and i also
obtained my cdl last year as well so
what are you going to go do
drive truck most likely
what about going with the fed
yeah i mean it's just a longer process
and until
i would go drive truck until that
process was complete it can sometimes
take
six 12 18 months do you need out of law
enforcement that bad are you just cooked
yeah i mean we're just me and my family
we're just we're just done with it gotta
be done
we're ready to move on from it okay
i'm sorry yeah it's been a hard few
years man
um
all right i i can't do it in my head and
i can't do it in two minutes on the air
even with a good calculator probably
okay so um because the three variables
are the horrible rate of return the
eight year wait before you get anything
and then so what is 33 000 for the rest
of your life worth beginning eight years
from now
and 40 years old here and um you know
but i mean what's that present value the
net present value of that
versus 85 000
going in
minus the fact you would have gotten 25
000 in your pocket
i think it's going to work out where you
take the the 25 000 and you go on with
your life it's probably going to work
out better for you
that's my guess and you roll your roll
your 450s you roll your 457 over into an
ira
um you just forget about the pension
yeah and just forget about the pension
because i think the pensions i think
it's a
i think it's a trap
but i can't do the math in my head fast
enough to guarantee you that so uh jump
on ramsey solutions.com
click on smart investor pro find someone
that helps you do investing in your area
they'll run the math out for you and say
this group of 33 000 is worth this in
today's dollars because it doesn't start
for eight years and it's based on a six
percent and then you can back into it
and figure it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality author
the brand new number one bestseller own
your past change your future own your
past change your future is my co-host in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage they're here donny and
keona are with us hey guys how are you
hey doing well how are you welcome where
do you guys live uh moorhead minnesota
awesome
welcome to nashville how much debt did
you guys pay off uh 118 thousand five
dollars way to go how long did that take
35 months all right and your range of
income during that time uh we started at
about 74 000 and our highest year was
102 000. 102. good for you what do you
guys do for a living uh so i'm a
certified athletic trainer
i'm a senior program coordinator for a
nonprofit oh good cool what kind of debt
was your hundred and eighteen thousand
oh we had a little bit of everything we
had a majority of it was our student
loans about eighty
uh we had a car loan a credit card a
second mortgage
just the normal you're normal yeah how
long you been married
we're coming up on
six years seven years the confidence you
have is astounded
and it wasn't even me that wasn't
confident hey hey i'm glad i won you
that slipped up that's all i'm saying
all i know is hey how much debt it's
this much this much in five bucks how
long you been married
it out close enough
all right so six years give or take and
halfway through that six years give or
take 35 months ago you said
something's got to change tell me your
story what happened so we were two years
into our marriage at that point we just
had our first
she was about six months old and we
recognized that our current lifestyle
and financial situation was not
sustainable when we added in child care
finances
ouch the bite yes the opportunity was
presented um to take fpu i presented it
to my husband he said i don't think we
really need that
because we're doing so good yeah i
thought we were we were doing
everything's fine we can't pay the
daycare bill but everything's fine
exactly
um so we took the course and from that
point um
well when we took the course i was kind
of nervous but donnie dove right into it
yeah i dove right in i think i bought
four year books right away and oh wow i
read them all in probably a span of two
weeks oh my gosh
we dove in so keanu you're like oh my
god what have i created i thought he was
gonna make me sell our brand new car
that we just bought so
i was a little nervous but we didn't you
didn't you paid it off paid it off all
right that'll work too good good yeah so
uh when you went through the class all
you got was nerves
[Laughter]
and i yep and i was just ready i said
yeah
came on okay all right and you're a
certified trainer yeah athletic trainer
yeah so nothing is worse than you
sitting down with an athlete and saying
here's what you need to do for the next
three weeks and they're like sure got it
coach and they do none of it exactly so
you know the value of following a plan
yep yeah i'm going all in good for you
man yeah that makes it easy the
correlation between the behavior change
is almost identical i mean it's pretty
incredible so well done you guys thank
you very very fun all right outside the
two of you who were your biggest
cheerleaders
oh we were pretty low-key about telling
a lot of people what we were doing um
obviously our our family knew what we
were doing and
yep our financial peace class yeah one
of keon's co-workers got us into that
um i would say we had a lot more
naysayers than true cheerleaders but
um that just helped drive us even more
so what are they saying now
they're like oh don't worry you'll go
back into debt at some point oh yeah
they're coming they're gonna fall
they're gonna go all the way i said no
double down on stupid okay exactly oh my
gosh what was the what was the
the best marriage uh disagreement you
had
the best marriage disagreement that's
oxymoronic very much so
um what was the biggest freaking fight
you had
that's a good question i mean once once
we got in like
obviously our our monthly budget
meetings really impacted the way we
communicated in our marriage once she
knew you weren't eyeing her car yeah
yeah exactly but no i think honestly
it wasn't any big disagreement we just
our communication got so much better
once we started that
we were able to truly talk like adults
to each other what about personal
sacrifice what's the thing you were into
are you into shoes or weight programs or
what were the things you were into that
you gave up the last you know i think it
was just that instant gratification like
i i loved shopping at the time and so
not going out and shopping and buying
whatever i wanted
um that was a little bit difficult it
took a lot of
behavioral changes that impacted our
finances but the communication within
our monthly budget and having to be able
to say like
yeah i spent x amount of dollars at
whatever store it was and being open
about that
um i didn't want to disappoint not that
i would disappoint him but i wanted to
honor the sacrifices that we were making
together and being
um respectful of that so that we could
have those conversations i think that
that really it's incredible good words
honor respect yeah that's good words
yeah i would say my biggest one was i i
like to go out and have a good time with
my friends and you know there's just a
lot of times where i had to say no or we
had to change our plans to just hang out
at the house and grill or something like
that so yeah i think the biggest change
actually was when the pandemic started
uh kiana started cutting my hair so
um didn't have to spend thirty dollars a
month man but it looks great it looks
good right yeah
we weren't going to bring it up but
it's awesome
you guys are fun well done you feel
powerful oh yeah yeah that's for sure i
feel like you're in control now huh yeah
are your naysayers right will you ever
go back absolutely not i think one of
the biggest things too um when we
started our journey we had a six month
old and she
we had the goal to hit debt free before
she hit kindergarten and she just turned
four last month
yeah boom yeah mic drop i love it good
for you guys so very well done so very
well done see they will not go back in
that because that would be disrespecting
the sacrifice that they had made that's
right and it would
make their knuckleheaded friends right
you can't let that yeah this is true
that's a big enough motivation right
there just to not cave for you goobers i
love it way to go you guys we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you we're
so proud of you the way to go thank you
and that's the next chapter in your
story is number one bestseller how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you will too in your case uh
copy a total money makeover for you to
give away to one of those knuckleheads
maybe you can get them started and uh
you might even use this we've got the uh
a one year subscription to financial
peace university which of course was a
big part of your story and the every
dollar premium version of the app is
part of that it's the ramsey plus one
year deal we're going to give you a gift
card for a whole year for that you can
either give that away or you can go back
through it whatever you want to do but
that gives you a chance to pay it
forward and tell your story and maybe
maybe inspire some other people to
change their lives yeah so good for you
guys very very well done
all right donny and keon fargo north
dakota area 100 and
that wasn't what you said you didn't say
fargo north dakota did you no it's
they're connected morehead minnesota and
fargo north dakota they're connected
minnesota yep okay moorhead minnesota
all right i knew i didn't hear dakota
all right 118 000 paid off in 35 months
making 74-102
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're free
[Applause]
this is how it's done
you know these this is interest these
are interesting words in his world of uh
personal
training your world of therapy where
someone is
you know is called to engage a difficult
truth and make a change
about my physical
uh
habits my money habits my emotional
mental health spiritual habits
in every case
uh honoring
the sacrifices made respecting
those are two great words
and one that kind of almost goes with
that that i hear
i had to submit myself to the plan
meaning i thought i had it all figured
out but here i sat broke so i must not
so i've got to submit myself i've got to
actually agree to do it
which means i wasn't right yeah that
that
i asked somebody one time how do we move
forward and that was the answer is you
got to look back and acknowledge i hurt
people when i said this or did this i
hurt myself i dishonored myself i didn't
i didn't i'm not as smart as i thought
it was so i didn't all my schemes
i got to submit to the plan that works i
got to submit to something different
than me yes and that's
a little bit of the 12-step thing
admitting i'm powerless that's exactly
that's exactly what that is just taking
a knee and saying what i'm doing now
it's like that famous quote is this
making your life better and you've got
to look in there and go it's not
continuing to do the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
the definition of insanity yeah
they're a sharp couple very sharp this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today michelle is with us in
atlanta hi michelle welcome to the
ramsay show
hello how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well i'm calling to ask the question
today
i want to know how what is the best way
to tackle adept as a single mother of a
18 year old starting college in the fall
and an annual income of 24 to 26 000
and a total depth of 56 thousand four
hundred and six dollars
wow what's the uh 56 000 on
that student loan
car total
and a loan how much is the car
the car is 15 000 now okay
all right wow
um
well you've been fighting this battle a
long time hadn't you kiddo
i had yeah
you raised that kid your whole his whole
life by yourself
i have you're a princess warrior yeah
you're a rock star
thank you so much so i'll give you some
mathematical observations
and then we have to convert those to
real life okay okay mathematical
observation number one is
if i woke up in your shoes i would be
looking
for what my next new career is because
your income sucks
right that's not a shaming thing it's i
think you're probably worth more than
you're getting paid especially if you
went and did something else
yeah i'm trying to that's not a not nice
way of saying you don't make much money
don't make enough money
okay hard to make it on 25 000 bucks yes
out there in today's world okay what do
you do
i'm a dialysis technician
okay
so what could you do to gear up uh some
further certifications may be in the
medical field
that would increase your income almost
immediately any ideas
immediately
i mean like if you took a six-month
class at night
by christmas you'd be making double or
something i mean is there stuff like
that out there
i mean there is certifications in the
healthcare field like um medical billing
and coding
no i'm talking about like
moving up in what you do is a hands-on
you assist in a medical procedure today
yes and if you were assisting in a
different medical procedure or further
in depth with that procedure and made
more i'd be happy with that if you like
doing what you're doing that is and i
got a feeling you've been doing it a
while
uh two years
and a lot of hospitals have
uh you know go back and get your
bachelor's and we'll pay for it but you
owe us two years afterwards things like
that that you can possibly pursue here
right yeah okay so thing number one
mathematically agree with me we're going
to work on our income
because that's part of your equation
there's two parts of the equation the
income and the out go
so if we get the income up some of this
starts to solve itself doesn't it
like if you made 50 000 instead of 25
000 that uh no kidding right
you kind of already knew that before you
called me
but you know my point is i think you
need to be actively saying hey 10 years
from today i want to be making 75 000
and here's the five steps i've got to do
to get there
and doing whatever that is i don't care
and it's something you like don't do
something you hate but i'm saying go
make some more money number one number
two
the longer you are in twenty five
thousand dollar income range
the more you have to look in the mirror
and say i can't afford a fifteen
thousand dollar car when i make twenty
five thousand dollars a year
when you have in when you have items
that are going down in value that you
pay payments on
cars
uh anything with a motor or wheels
it it
that are more than half your annual
income it makes it very difficult in
other words your car is a big part of
your problem
as a percentage of your income
so if you made 75 000 i wouldn't be
worried about a fifteen thousand dollar
car debt we just knock it out
but at 25 that's some pretty heavy
lifting you mean you got a you got a
medium-sized hole and a small shovel
these are my math observations
okay so you can do the stuff we teach
right where you are
but it's just going to be very hard
because you just making month to month
has been hard for a long time that's why
i called you a warrior princess
you've been fighting it i know what your
budget looks like there's no room in
your budget
yeah so we got to get your income up and
your outgo down and the more we do of
each of those
the more
money we find to throw at getting rid of
the debt and then throw at building
wealth so that you retire with dignity
so can we go to part can we go to part
three now
okay
you got a kid heading into college right
i do
and
for 18 years you've scratched and clawed
and said
this this generational stuff stops with
me
and my kid's gonna have something better
is that right
right
do not
go sign a bunch of parent plus loans
that you will never be able to pay back
for some expensive school
okay
okay conversation that you all need to
have right now about going to school is
here is the financial reality of our
world
and whatever state we happen to be in
here's what a community college looks
like for two years and hear me say my
mom went to community college
and then went on to work at one of the
biggest companies on the planet then got
a phd and is now in her 70s still a
professor
so anybody who bags on community college
doesn't know what they're talking about
and you can do it for a fraction of the
cost of a larger institution i know this
game because i worked in it for a long
time and they look at moms and dads and
say
they will mortgage their souls for this
picture of what this kid's going to get
and i'm telling you don't do that
this we're breaking we're breaking
cycles here is that you hear what i'm
saying
yeah i want your kid to go to school if
college is in y'all's future i want him
to go i think college is great but i
want you to go to a school that y'all
can afford to he can work his way
through community college for the first
two years if it's not free in your
community in your state
so if i load you up with a bunch of
materials
will you use them and learn about
getting out of debt and getting them
into school debt free
i will use them i will use them i will
use them okay because i'm gonna load you
up as my gift because i think you're a
pretty impressive lady amazing so uh
so here i'm gonna i wanna sign you up
for financial peace university for a
year
and it includes every dollar the world's
best budgeting app to help you manage
your month money and learn about money
like you've never done before okay we're
gonna give you that i'm gonna send you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose about how to get a better
career going for you
you got to read that okay i'm also going
to send you a copy of one of our small
books called debt free degree
on how you can go to college debt free
and let me tell you we've studied the
student loan mess that's out there and
we've studied it and studied it and
we're really on top of it and let me
tell you a disturbing thing that we
discovered
regardless of race
regardless of income
the number one person that does
unbelievably stupid stuff when they go
to college is if their parents didn't go
to college to show and didn't know the
way to show them where the landmines
were
and the parents instead go oh all
college is wonderful because i wish i
had gone in college college college
college college and they mortgage their
soul and they sign them up at some
expensive thing where they're paying 15
times what they should be paying for the
same degree and they study the wrong
stupid thing like get a degree in
left-handed puppetry with a 250 000
worth of student loan debt from some
stupid butt school that they should
never been in the first place the number
one person that does that is someone who
didn't have parents in college it's not
a shame on the parents that didn't go to
college they just don't know the ropes
and they don't know where all the land
mines are and the kid wanders through
and just land mines are going off
everywhere and they wake up at 30 years
old 200 000 in debt but by god they got
a college degree which is freaking
worthless uh because you know getting a
degree in left-handed puppetry and
medieval art is ridiculous you know and
you can't do squat with it you end up
being a barista
so that's what you've got to avoid here
all right hang on we're going to send
you all that stuff michelle and you call
us back while you're walking all this
out we'll help you with a career we'll
help you with the money we'll help you
with the kid going to school we'll help
you with every bit of it we actually
know how to do all of those things
you're amazing this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality
author of the number one best-selling
book that just hit number one the other
day own your past change your future
a not so complicated process about
relationships
and mental wellness jump in we'll talk
to you we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five colt is in montgomery alabama hi
colt how are you
i'm doing well dave thank you how are
you better than i deserve what's up
well first i'll start out i'm absolutely
emotionally mentally
in almost every way fashion exhausted
um financially i read your book in 2018
um when i was on my last military
deployment i'm actually active military
i've been in ten years now thank you for
joining us that's mine
thank you i appreciate it
so read your book got motivated uh
started following your steps paid off
almost forty thousand dollars in debt uh
in just the first nine months of being
on your plan
then in 2019 i thought well i'm in a
better position i'm going to buy a
fixer-upper house i can do all the work
myself from blue collar
old farm boy
thought i could take care of it well
four months later military dropped me
orders and i'm stuck with this house and
i'm like i can't really rent it out in
the status
so i made the dumb decision and panicked
and
put a whole lot of work into the house
on credit cards
and the last two years i've just been
treading water the tenants that i had in
it for two years uh trashed it so all
the work i put into it
pretty much was just undone
um
and then i had uh
thought really passively last summer
about selling it because the market's
hot
but then i thought no i'm still not
ready to part with it's an investment
i'll get a roommate from that's a best
friend from another state move him and
he was happy to move in and then we
walked in the door and went oh my gosh
this house
so
i'm sorry what's wrong with the house
they
were shown without a shower curtain so
the deal this week was is the wall in
the bathroom
uh buckled inward so i spent two weeks
of pto or leave i completely gutted and
raided the bathroom
uh every blind in the house was gone uh
just to filth
um this is the room
no no this is their roommate this is the
tenant oh that's when you discovered the
sentence okay so then you panicked and
you went on credit cards and you built
it back right
so what kind of condition is it in today
it's in a position where
it's it still needs paint um
kitchen's still a mess
but i mean it's livable
mm-hmm but
what do you know
uh 140.
and how much credit card debt did you
run up
uh 35 000. what would it sell for today
as it sits
talked to a realtor the other day she
said probably around 2 30.
sell it
you would sell it there was nothing in
your conversation with me that sounded
fun so far you suck at this real estate
thing
everything you've touched has turned to
poop on this man
yes get rid of it there's nothing here
fun i've
yeah i've been working in addition to
school
you breathed better
i know when i said you sound like you
went thank god
hey and dude listen i
you and i could probably talk for an
hour um you you and me and dave talk for
an hour
you've got other stuff in your life
going on don't you
yes way too much and you're running 10
years
on deployment return and deployment
return
and i hear your voice is crackling
you're fried is that right yeah
especially after last week you've got to
get some margin yeah get some stuff off
your plate even if that means go live on
base go wrench yeah fire yourself from
anything you can to make your life
simpler
i i really needed to hear that because
that's what i told myself when i was
driving home i said i've got to make my
life more simple
calm like almost boring you need some
boredom go talk to a counselor yeah go
pick up take up fishing
go you got to find some people hang out
with some people that aren't in the
middle of enough take up fishing well i
was gonna say golf and then i thought i
love him he loves our country so i don't
encourage golf um but hey look you got
to get some friends you got you have to
your life has been living you for a
decade
and it's been one of service and one of
a lot of trauma and a lot of exhaustion
and this real estate thing's just one
more chapter yeah
where it's riding you you're not riding
it
so i'm not telling you again military
just keep doing what you're doing but
you got to create a life like okay now i
got to crest this wave kind of like
dave is a great ski instructor and when
you first start skiing and you're
sitting in the water and you come out
and it's just blasting you in the face
eventually you can stand up and you
crest and you get on top of that thing
boats still going the same speed
everything's still going the same except
you're on top of it that's what we're
talking about and that talks about
that's you backing up and deciding i'm
gonna do some things in my life
differently so i can be well what else
can you fire yourself from
well the second other job that i picked
up on the side that i'm exhausted
washing campers up in the hot alabama
sun bring in some extra cash
you don't need extra cash we just got
rid of the house and put some money in
your pocket you're debt free
yeah that would be great
move on base get a one bedroom apartment
just control all delete man
go to the gym laugh right go play god
don't play golf but whatever
right get some joy in your life man
you've worked too hard and you've given
too much of yourself to continue to run
like this go to the range and drop a
thousand rounds downrange that's
stressful
and the government will pay for it
the only other question i have though is
just
my roommate just moved down best friend
moved down just in february i'm still
trying to figure out how i hand him a
little bit of a check when his house
sells hand him a little bit of a check
give him five grand and say go get him
no give him if you gave him a thousand
dollars and said i'm sorry i gotta get
out of this this is killing me
the thousand dollars is just to say i'm
sorry what would he say
okay
he would we was good at friends as we
are i think he would be perfectly fine
with that but it's still just the
emotion like i feel like i failed him
you feel no there's that that
that's how i feel about it also so
there's that that part of it well it's
why you're serving the military your
amount of honor
all right so you're going to always have
those feelings about things and they're
always going to be about 2x what reality
is
yeah yeah you did fail him but it ain't
near as big as it feels like inside of
you
in other words no big deal okay
if his life was all hooked up he
wouldn't have come
[Laughter]
right it didn't like you disjointed some
guy from his medical degree
he didn't have nothing to do anyway
that's why he lives in your house yeah
so yeah i mean he it's okay he's gonna
be all right
um yeah give him a thousand bucks to say
thank you or i'm sorry or whatever you
want to call it and call that honor and
it is honor and um
help him some other way if you can
without signing up for some extra job
quit washing campers
go put a thousand rounds downrange get
yourself in a simplified life boring
life
[Music]
and i'm gonna send you a copy of john's
book own your past to change your future
you need to read this book hold on
you're gonna love it you're gonna go oh
there i am
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
well the housing market over the last
couple of years has been unique to say
the least home prices have gone up like
a rocket
hungry buyers are pouncing on homes as
they hit the market and now there's a
plot twist the fed has upped the ante
and raised the fed funds rate for the
first time in three years
and that means we're seeing some tick up
in mortgage rates
and that's got a lot of you worried
about higher mortgage rates and maybe
even a recession
might make buying and selling a home
more difficult so let's all just take a
little breath
turn off the news
click
get a little perspective a whole lot
goes into buying and selling a home
market conditions and mortgage rates are
part of it but they don't drive the
whole thing
anytime you're looking to buy or sell a
home you need to do your homework you
need to go pro in your corner who knows
what they're doing this is your largest
asset it is not amateur hour
so get a high quality high octane real
estate agent in your corner
regardless of what's going on out there
you will do a better transaction as a
buyer
and certainly as a seller in this
environment
so if you want to know about this head
on over to ramseysolutions.com
rates
we've got some good
good information there on what's
happening with the rates
and how that affects you go to ramsey
solutions dot com slash agent and you
can talk to one of our endorsed local
providers that are ramsey trusted and
they'll help you
help you navigate uh these stormy waters
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal
all right today's question comes from
jose in brazil and jose writes
i currently earn 45 to 50 000 a year
working for a law firm and i have some
clients on the side i'm debt free i have
a 12 month emergency fund invest 20 of
my income and i live with my mother
while i'm saving for a home down payment
and to pay for a small wedding i have
trouble spending money on myself
consider myself generous but when it
comes to spending money on me i'm
paralyzed i desperately need a new
computer but i worry about things on the
news shows so i save my money instead
it's like i always find an excuse to not
spend money now i'm anxious about taking
on a mortgage when i get married how can
i get over this mental block
ah
what do you think dave
i got all kinds of feelings
[Laughter]
um
turn off the new shows
there's one
um
because they're skewing your view of the
future
and they're um
just about all of them have turned into
the national enquirer
i mean case in point the leading news
stories
on all the major networks which used to
be credible is ufos
so i mean the national enquirer has now
invaded every one of them
um so i mean seriously we had a slow
news day
um or if you were biden and you wanted
to throw something shiny out and cause
people look at it right quick let's just
have a testimony before senate on ufos
in case somebody would look at that
instead of gas prices you know so um oh
my gosh so anyway so i i no get away
from that crap i remember this um person
not specifically but from my days back
working with law students and it was a
very common sentiment that i think we
can all have some sort of yeah i can see
that which is
a manic powerful i'm gonna accomplish
this so that i can get this so that i
can get this so that when i get wherever
it is i'm going i'm finally gonna go ah
and this guy got ah and it doesn't exist
because if you're not dealing with the
underlying anxiety
which is this young man comes from a
situation where there was a lack of
safety i can guarantee you this young
man comes from a place where um
relationships were something that were
done to him they were not
there was not engagement there i can
guarantee you and he is trying to solve
that rattling that goes on inside his
body with
this and with this and i'm gonna double
the emergency fund i'm gonna invest even
more i'm gonna
i'm gonna get married i'm gonna buy a
house i'm gonna have a computer i'm
gonna do clients and then i'm gonna have
clients on the side i'm gonna do it all
and here's what's happened you're just
gonna have a bigger collapse because at
the end of the day you gotta pay the
piper which is you got to heal
and so
the getting it's not getting over this
particular mental block it's healing
your body and it is healing your
approach to how you do life now some of
the some of the pushback i get on this
dave
dude there's a lot of problems in the
world and we need some really great
attorneys out there we need some great
innovative people that need to work
really hard for over a long period of
time i want people to be ambitious to
work really hard but i want people to
know that
that's not going to solve you
healing and relationships and running
hard can all be done at the same time
well as you say in one of your talks
winning
does not make you well that's right
so you can win the super bowl and you
still have to go home with you there you
go and you you cross the finish line and
then you look around go for what right
for what and so jose here's what i want
you to do man
um yes you need to spend some money and
so right now you need some discipline
you're gonna have to change your
identity and we've talked about that you
have to change who you see yourself as
right now you see yourself as this
frugal guy who's a planner and
you got to change your identity brother
and you got to be somebody who is
generous and who enjoys life and you
don't know how to do that you got to
practice it
and
i want you to begin healing from this
anxiety because this has been a long
time coming my guess is living at home
with mom may not be the best thing for
you right now and so that may be step
one of practicing this is getting your
own place even paying rent which is
going to slow down your down payment and
i'm good with that
but that's a lot of me read into
somebody that i've never talked to
before what do you think dave
yeah i'm reading in i mean i believe in
hard work i believe in getting it i do
pretty much yeah i do too i do pretty
much everything wide open but i have
learned to get a little rhythm where
there's some margin and i have a moment
where i just sit and breathe and um i
don't have to do it for two hours every
day
but i have to do it every so often i
mean sunday is a good time as an example
there's a reason for a sabbath right and
um so you need some rhythm where you
just breathe
where you just sit and breathe
and uh and and not turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn turn which means you
don't have any screens in front of you
while you're breathing screens don't
help you breathe and uh news channels
for sure don't help you breathe
so but my time with you dave
as hard as you run
and i'm simple i love i love going hard
i love going like i like just getting it
done and getting it done
i've never got a sense from you that if
i win over here and i increase my net
worth that ah
my employees are all going to be well my
leadership team is going to be great and
my marriage can be perfect
you invest equally and i got to make
sure we're having these conversations i
got to make sure we say this again and
we say it again we say it again we're
training these people so this is awesome
and it's important and it's not the
end-all be-all right yeah i mean there's
just a there's a difference between
frying yourself out and working hard
that's exactly i love that what it comes
down to and it has to do with the margin
and the rhythm
and some sabbath and the peace
you need that purpose yeah you have a
time where you consciously realize every
so often and it's not once a year
but it's not once a day necessarily but
where you consciously breathe in
and you just feel peace yeah for a
second which means nothing's bothering
you for a second
they'll be planning to bother you later
don't worry about it it'll come around
but but i mean you just it because that
that what that is is what we're
discovering and craig rochelle and i
were talking about this on his
leadership podcast a little while back
um
that one of the things we're discovering
is that during the pandemic those of us
that were doing business
during the quarantines and the shutdowns
and the economic disruption and the uh
alien invader called fauci and all of
these things i think he was actually
while they were doing those alien
testimonies before senate but um i think
he's actually an alien but i'm i'm going
to personally invite him yeah but the uh
uh but any i mean he does well anyway
the uh
in the middle of all that we
you know we were like ah we're gonna get
through this you know you know hold your
breath grit your teeth push through
we're gonna fight through we're going to
survive this thing we're not going to
lose everything you know we're going to
do what it takes we're going to be
proactive and and frenetic if we need to
and what craig and i were talking about
was it just burnt everybody down to
their last fuse there you go and instead
of
instead of just
getting back to normal
you have the before you can get back to
any kind of version of normal you got to
fill the tank back up because you
drained it to nothing a bunch of us i
was going to say you but i did yeah i
did that too and i i so i spent you know
i started talking to craig craig and i
started talking about that about he's
one of the best leaders i know
one of the largest churches in america
he's a wonderful pastor and we were
talking about this just over dinner back
about six or eight months ago and ever
since then i went okay i gotta make sure
i'm filling the tank back up and just
make a conscious effort because if
you're just running on constant gear on
gear with no oil you just fry the thing
out dude so that's what's going on here
jose that'll help you do this that'll
help you relax and then you'll spend
money this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book own your past change your future is
my co-host today heather's in cincinnati
hi heather how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i wanted to call in and see i um
i've come accumulated debt over the
years and i'm over the age of 50 and i'm
trying to get financial peace but one of
the
holdups of me
going through with your program is that
i just feel like it's too late in my
life to actually be able to pay off all
my debt and then
be able to accumulate enough money for
retirement
oh absolutely you're completely ancient
you're so old
there's no chance you're going to make
it what are you talking about girl
there's nothing in our stuff told you
you were too old i'm 61 for god's sake i
can still make that that's old you're
not old
i just feel like we've got i've had so
many things like just dangling on my
life with debt that i've never been able
to just get paid off and i want to get
it
off and i want to be able to do it
that's most people how much doubt have
you got how much you
um i've got about 85 in student loans
between my husband and i my husband's 68
and then i have 12 000 in irs and
um some car loans
and then we still haven't promoted
finance to 15. about um i was trying to
figure that out about 24 i think
okay what's your household income no i'm
sorry it's 18 18. i'm sorry um household
income i bring in 90 my husband is
retired he's bringing in about
1500 a month plus 300 a week
for a part-time job
okay
so you bring in about 30. okay
she got like 120 to work with you 85 12
to the irs and 18 what kind of student
loans does he have at 68 years old
um
we went through a bad time he had a
heart issue and so we ended up going um
where he had to put him on suspension or
whatever and so they've just been
sitting out there but he went back to
school late in life he went back around
55 okay
to get his master's degree
what did he retire from
um facility
management okay
um any chance he could go back to work
um for two years
is he is he physically able
physically probably but just not
mentally i don't think he would mentally
want to do that but i didn't ask if he
would want to i don't care about wants i
don't want to be 85 000 in debt when i'm
68 years old and i got a 51 year old
wife i'm getting really saddled with
this mess
yeah
hey yeah heather how
i i just got to uh
you are real real close if not already
crossed over that line from being
frustrated and burned out to resentment
aren't you
well i don't know that i'm resentful
it's just i'm nervous that i've got
we've got a lot here that we need to pay
off and there's i just don't it's gonna
be difficult it is but
you rolling this out and you're making
90 000 and him making 30 and him he's
not gonna want to
all right so here's the deal okay you
can do this on 110
and uh if we say 85 and 30
is um 120 huh 125 right
okay
so how fast do you pay off 125 making
120
well if you lived on 60 000 you would do
it in two years and some change
if you live on more than that it's gonna
take you three years and some change but
you're gonna have no life for the next
three years my personal recommendation
would be that bubba go back to work
during that time whether he wants to or
not for two years and you guys clean it
all up in two years and throw fifty
thousand bucks in the bank at the end of
the three you two years he's 70 you're
53 you're dead free with 50 grand in the
bank
but the faster you do this and the more
harsh
circumstances you put your life in
so that you have extra money to throw at
this
meaning harsh meaning he goes back to
work he didn't want to you guys have
absolutely no freaking life
i'm talking drop an atomic bomb on your
lifestyle don't talk to me about going
on vacation
i'm retired well kiss my butt you're
broke
okay
and so uh you know not a chance here you
got to get after this and both of you
got to get after this and it sounds like
he's
emotionally in coast mode
and you're in freak out worried mode
you're ready to go frenetic on this and
go crazy and you're afraid you're going
to drag him that's what i think i'm
hearing between the lines am i reading
that wrong
well he's agreed to do the program with
me because i did talk to him about it
he's agreed to do whatever until he
found out the program then he was going
back to work
until he found that out correct we
haven't talked about that
that probably will change things in here
well if he gets really enthused about
what this will do for you
and he wants to do this as an offer of
service to his wife
he'll find some energy to go do some of
these things i don't know exactly what
that is but he's got a master's degree
and i think he's got earning potential
and i think he's got a little gas left
in the tank
and
you're telling me that a lot of this
mess is his
uh or is related to him it's your all's
mess because you're married both of you
are into this but yeah that's what i
would do so i can give you great hope to
the extent that i can get both of you
enthused excited
on board
fired up so much that you're willing to
sacrifice and you put whatever you want
to put in the bucket called sacrifice
but sacrifice means the income goes up
and the
in and the outgo goes down and the
difference is thrown at this and you can
mathematically clean this up in two to
three years
prefer it to be two years with some
money in the bank at the end of the
story so hang on we're going to sign you
up for financial peace university we'll
show you couples just like you two that
have done this time and time and time
and time again just do a little
scrolling through the youtube
debt debt-free screams and you'll find
some couples just like you that are
doing this just like him just like you
just like the two of you
uh and you know you can pull this off
but
he needs to hear your heart
on how worried you are that he's going
to die and leave you with this
because that's under all this it's
freaking you out and really it kind of
should be yeah i don't want you to be
completely freaked out but i want to be
worried enough to do something about it
i would love to see you go to a coffee
shop by yourself and write down what do
i need right now like what what what
what do i need from my husband and it
might be that y'all never sat down and
had that directive a conversation and i
need you to plug in on this because i
need to be free from underneath all of
this debt and
i think we're getting part of the story
here dave but you got irs here this is a
big long heart attack heart issues along
the way there's been a lot of stuff
going on here man and so i would love
love love to see
see heather i'd love to see you write
your needs down and then go sit down
with your husband and say him out loud
hang on we'll pick up and uh austin i'll
pick up in there and get you guys signed
up for ramsey plus for the uh financial
peace university and get you going we'll
try to help you call in any time we'll
walk with you but we're going to tell
you the truth we're going to be blunt
you can tell that all right william's
with us in dallas hi william how are you
i'm good sir good how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
um so
i am in a
my wife and i have
been working
on
your baby steps um
i am in a position where i can make a
gigantic leap into a different
job
um
i have interviewed for the job
he called me the same day i applied for
it
i interviewed for it he gave me pretty
much a huge rundown of the whole company
and everything like that
um
and i've gone back up there and asked
and just
just kind of stuck my head in his office
and said hey i'm still interested if if
you hear anything let me know that was
two weeks ago
oh it's inside your current company
no it's not inside my current company
so you just dropped in and stuck your
head in his office was a small business
yes sir okay and approximately 15 people
work there
okay uh do it again and this time ask
him when he's planning to make a
decision
could be better in person or email in
person yeah person is always better
what date do you plan because otherwise
i need to know because if i need to look
for something else you tell me it's okay
i just need to know what's going on i
don't want to pester you but i won't be
professional enough to follow up and by
what date do you plan on doing this deal
or not doing this deal and if it's not
me just let me know it's okay
and
you know he'll appreciate that
directness if he's a small business guy
he's gotten too busy and he hasn't
followed up and he's dropping the ball
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
roxanne's in portland hi roxanne what's
up
hi dave
i am doing pretty good i'm calling with
a question about uh baby step four my
husband and i are just starting this
part of our journey and i'm wondering if
i should
max out my
401k or
meet my match for my employer and max
out my roth iras
as well 401k available as a roth
um it's not a rock it's traditional
is it available as a roth they don't
they don't offer that at your at your
office
correct okay
all right here there's a rule of thumb
okay mathematically match
beats roth
beats traditional
okay so what that would tell you to do i
think in your situation are you married
i am okay so i would do my match
it still gets more kind it's more
complicated then because we're doing
this as a household with both of your
offerings
not just you as a single person because
you're not a single person
so as a household because you can you
know name him as your beneficiary he can
name you as his beneficiary what's yours
is mine is yours in divorce court anyway
when it comes to retirement accounts so
all that to say
um you're perfectly safe and perfectly
fine for it to be heavier in one name or
the other does he have a 401k
he does not and he does not have access
to one okay he is a business a small
business owner perfect perfect okay
does he have employees
he does not okay very easy all right so
he has a sep available to him a
simplified employee pension plan or a
simple ira which is a 401k for small
business and
he has a traditional individual roth ira
available to him
so rule of thumb and all of those are
available as roths by the way
so roth beats traditional but match
beats everything so if we take your
total household income
15 of that total income
is your baby step four contribution turn
that into an actual dollar amount
and let's just make that up let's just
call that 25 000 is 15 of your income
what is your income by the way household
between the two of us 120 000
gosh i got pretty close okay so 17 18
000 bucks okay is your 15 of your
situation all right so let's call it 18
and how much is your match
my match is half of six percent that's
three questions
three percent if you put in six correct
okay so you're gonna put in six what do
you make
i make about a hundred thousand
he makes twenty thousand bucks at a
small business
it's the not it's not a
he plays music for a living
not much
he plays dance anyway
i bet he plays a ton to still even make
that
yeah yeah
okay um so
uh a whole nother discussion all right
so the
we're trying to get to eighteen thousand
you make a hundred thousand you're gonna
put in six thousand in order to get that
three percent match
all right
okay you follow me yeah we're trying to
get to 18 so we still need to do 12. so
if we did two roth iras at six each
one in each of your names you'd be fine
great that's exactly what i was thinking
yeah you would get there and sit down
with smart investor pro and they'll help
you pick out some good mutual funds we
always recommend spreading you're
investing across four types of mutual
funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and
international but dave have you looked
at the stock market
my 401k is a 201k what is wrong with you
well here's what's an interesting thing
cnbc just printed this out nearly 40
percent of investors who pulled money
out of markets in the last year
regretted it
oh so you figured out that when you pull
money out of the market that it's a dumb
idea because you usually pull it out
when it's down so you bought high and
sold low that's kind of the opposite of
what you ought to be doing all right
well the stock market is crazy dave
don't you know yeah i do know i just
pulled it up just a second ago let me
just tell you what it says today let's
see here today
the stock market is down in the past 12
months day over day
12 exact months
seven and a half percent
that is not crashing
bitcoin is down 52 percent that is
crashing that's a train wreck okay
that's a train over the mountain in a
black and white film wreck
okay
but that seven and a half percent is not
your 401k became a 201k you didn't lose
all your money now it's down from let's
see the high points january the 4th it
looks like 36 000 almost 37 000 dow and
the dow's down around 31 right now so
it's down more than seven and a half
percent since january but over the last
12 months
it's down seven and a half that's not
exactly a crash
it's not good i'd rather be up 17
i'm not happy about that but it's not
exactly reason for you to panic
time is the ultimate weapon when it
comes to investing said matt schultz the
chief credit analyst at lendingtree
gives younger investors a huge advantage
over their older counterparts
uh unfortunately however gen z and
millennials risk squandering that
advantage if they pull their money out
of the market when times get tough well
let me just help you with this map
all of you are stupid when you pull your
money out of the market when it gets
tough you don't have to be gen z
you can be uh maybe 50 60 70 years old
and you just go oh god and you sell low
that's just the worst possible time to
sell it ride the wave
trust that better times are ahead this
quote says and i agree with that ride
the wave so my quote always is those
that no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off in
the middle but here's an interesting
thing some 38 percent of investors said
they sold stocks last year due to a
current event
like extreme inflation ukraine whatever
according to a study from magnifymoney
of that group 40
so they wish they hadn't done it
the online survey of more than 1 000 us
consumers was conducted in a on april
15th and the other 60 just
wouldn't admit it yeah it wouldn't they
would they haven't seen it they still
haven't looked at it they still haven't
looked at it because here's here's an
interesting thing with the fear that
happens there
we've talked about this before where
there's psychological studies done that
say you have to gain three dollars to
feel like you broke even with a one
dollar loss
losses have more impact on your
psychology than gain does right more
negative impact than gain does positive
impact right and so in other words we
all like you know we all are negative
ninnies at our soul in some sense you
know and so uh
the thing that goes with that then
is this idea that that um
then they add a narrative
to it when they get out that is
hyperbole that's not true that's exactly
right okay so they say things like back
in 1987
black monday i lost everything in the
stock market
what do you what have you been listening
to your grandfather from the great
depression you didn't lose everything
the stock market didn't go to zero
you had the money in mutual funds and it
went down 25
in one day but you didn't it didn't go
to zero it was a cataclysmic event it
was not a good day but it didn't go to
zero
and so you didn't lose everything what
happened was you pulled your money out
at the bottom and you felt really stupid
because you were
stupid for doing that and then you had
to make up this story that made it sound
like the stock market is the villain
right and that you just got off on a
lifeboat just in time yeah well it was
just a you know it's not you don't put
money in there because i lost everything
back in the day right back in the day or
whatever i had all my money when it got
to zero and no it didn't it's
mathematically impossible
unless you had all your money in a
single company and that company went
completely broke and was liquidated and
they had no assets and the chapter 7
bankruptcy trustee couldn't sell the
assets and get a dime because that would
have been distributed to the
stockholders so i mean this is almost
physically impossible for you to get
absolutely zero now i lost a lot yeah or
i lost an amount that made me feel
really scared these are accurate
statements
but we have to add to this somehow to
put a stake in the ground
to somehow to create a story to offset
the fact that we know this was a bad
idea that's right and
nearly seventy percent of gen z
investors pulled money seventy percent
seven ten they have only known this bull
run for the last few years and they
don't know what even they don't know the
roller coaster goes down ever right so
here we go wait a minute it goes down
two who knows exactly so write it out
right now this is exactly the wrong time
to sell oh by the way
the market's down that means it's on
sale
this is the time to buy more time to
sell
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is a show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
this is also a baby steps millionaire
theme hour where we're going to talk to
real millionaires and find out how they
really did it
not someone that's broke with an opinion
or a political agenda
because there's a lot of people out
there running their mouth about where
wealth comes from it's always inherited
which is absolutely statistically
data-based bogus
so we're going to talk about this stuff
we're going to talk to real millionaires
a millionaire is someone with a 1
million dollar net worth there is no
other definition
making a million dollar income does not
make you a millionaire
making a two million dollar income does
not make you a millionaire
it could help you get there but a
million dollar net worth is the only
true definition
of a millionaire millionaire a million
dollar net worth or greater your net
worth is defined as your assets minus
your liabilities
not income producing
just assets if i don't produce an income
there's still an asset if you can sell
it and turn it into money it's an asset
now a lot of people argue about what you
can count in that or can't count in that
listen if it's an asset you can sell it
you can count it
whatever it is you got a stamp
collection it's it's it's an asset you
could sell it and turn it into money so
assets mass liabilities what you own
minus what you owe
equals a million dollars or greater than
you
are a millionaire sun chief starts us
off on this millionaire theme hour in
greensboro north carolina sanjeev what's
your net worth
so right now about 1.15
1.15 okay give me a little breakdown on
that how's that invested or what's it
what how did you get to a million one
five
sure about uh house home worth about 460
to
500 depending on the day of the week
and rest of it is in
in the stock market and retirement funds
and
uh
rainy day money and so on and so forth
about
670 or thousand in that okay all right
pretty simple okay how old are you
i am
64 this month 64.
yes sir my wife is 62. okay and
i need i need to bring something to it
to your notice that we only came to the
united states in 1994
and that year uh only i was allowed to
work
and i was making a whole of eighteen
thousand dollars a year
with uh four mouths to feed two young
young children
my wife and i and you came with uh no
wealth with you
uh ten thousand dollars that we had
saved while working in dubai
wow so you're
from dubai
okay and what is your i'm an indian i'm
an indian but i was working in dubai oh
okay all right and so what has been your
career
both of us are graduates from hotel
school
so we are in the service industry i've
also taught some at uncg
um
hospitality courses and one of my
catalans is
we got into hotel school because we were
not good enough to get into med schools
or engineering colleges
[Laughter]
however
we are doctors of ego because we we
brush everybody's ego and make them
happy and that makes us money oh
gosh what a burn dude who's that
that's fantastic that's great i like
that got a phd in ego
somebody else's okay uh
that's very good yes sir so um what was
the driving force why do you why did you
want to come to the us
uh it was just a chance that we took we
had no plans we had no great goals about
this is the best country to be in so on
and so forth
it's just something that happened
and i had a job opportunity come up
and uh
i just decided let's let's try it we are
young we can take the risk if we fail
india is great we can always go back
and that's how we
ended up here because even at that point
in time we had no debt we had nothing to
worry about in in terms of
you know life that way children were
very young and children
adopt and adapt to the uh to the
situation very very well and they're
they're all doing both kids are doing
well
and
so what do you what do you attribute
uh i mean when you look back on you say
okay i was able to become a millionaire
because
fill in the blank why
primary
my wife and i we work together hand in
hand always
and we live within our means uh
just just recently
my 95 year old mother had a stroke in
india and we had to travel at a short
notice
we we didn't have to finance that ticket
uh we we just decided we have to go uh
we got vacation from our
respective jobs because we are so loyal
and so working all the time anytime we
ask for something we just get it
though i was in business with for some
time too have i've decided to come back
into
into employment uh and because that
works best for my personality i think
so the data the data that i've seen that
if someone comes to america from another
country legally
that they are four times more likely to
become a millionaire than one of us that
was born here
i think you're right sir and
you know
in north may i mean we my wife and i did
it of course but without your talks and
your guidance it would have been a much
tougher task to achieve
and of course working together with the
spouse
and and then the other aspect is not
having multiple
spouses
it's very very important in life
your marriage is grand divorce is 50
grand that's what you're saying okay
okay
oh too fun so what would be your theory
as to why uh someone who immigrates
legally is more likely to build wealth
than one of us that was born here i've
got my theory but i'm curious what you
think
i i think
we we we come here because we want to
achieve something we want to prove it to
ourselves and our families back home
that that we can do it it's not just
that you know we are whatever
we have achieved but but at the same
time also people who come here from such
lands like india or southeast asia uh
it's a very poor part of the world
but not all of us there are poor either
but people who come here are highly
educated that's why you will see so many
uh you know phds and md's are from india
or pakistan or
southeast asian countries so they are
highly well educated
and
then they come here and they have
already learned the basics of economics
most of their parents
were living within their means we never
carried a debt
per se
and and
earlier in our life when my wife was
a homemaker
we never ever hired a babysitter
wow
came on came home honored to speak with
you sir what a blessing man good for you
very well done
1.15 million it's a baby steps
millionaire theme hour
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i've laughed a lot over the years that
how people have tried to call me it and
ramsey solutions an overnight success
yeah you work your butt off for 30 years
you're an overnight success
one of the things we did many years ago
was we were trying to communicate to our
team that
you know what happens is the things that
you do in business and leadership in
your life for that matter there's a
cumulative effect of them they begin to
build up build up build up and then
suddenly there's a breakthrough and it
appears to be suddenly and it's not
suddenly it's a it's the accumulation of
a work of work of a lot of years you
don't suddenly get a great marriage you
don't suddenly raise great kids you
don't suddenly
uh become a success and if you do it
very seldom lasts so we developed a
thing called the momentum theorem to
communicate to our team that there's
focused intensity
over time
multiplied by god equals unstoppable
unstoppable momentum it's a great
marketing principle it's a great
principle for any area of your life
and i've taught it now for years in
entre leadership and other leadership
settings it's a talk that i do
periodically on how that works and what
it is and our team decided that we need
to put that into a ramsey quick read
which these the little short books are
basically a chapter not a book
um and so we wrote the i wrote the
little book the little um you know the
description of the momentum theorem we
put a big cover on it and uh made a big
deal about it and john
not much there
but there's a lot there it's pretty thin
right i mean you've been making fun of
uh redefining anxiety about being a
pamphlet that's like an encyclopedia
compared to your book this uh yeah that
thing that thing's a tome
compared to compared to this 41 page uh
pulitzer prize winning not the event
here but i'll tell you what the
information in it i will stand by and i
will tell you it's worth 10 bucks okay
because if you get one good idea out of
something that's worth 10 bucks and uh
it's 41 pages so you can read it in
i don't know six eight minutes
it's really thin but hey i'll tell you
this though the feedback i'm continuing
to receive all over the country about
redefining anxiety is
so and so wouldn't read the people on my
team don't like reading big books they
don't like complicated stuff my
college student didn't like to
and so it's reaching a group of people
who need something i need to digest this
and own it now tonight that's enough
tonight in one setting yeah i'm not
going to read a book in eight settings
that's right yeah so i think that i
think the smaller books are this might
suck someone into into actually becoming
a reader
right yeah because it's a whole 41 pages
yeah it's on sale at ten dollars at
ramseysolutions.com and the scary thing
is we put it up for sale monday and it's
selling like crazy of course it is yes
it's fantastic so funny
oh and i'm not i'm not dissing you guys
for buying it i'm glad you bought it
thank you i appreciate that and it is
worth 10 bucks huh it's just humorous to
me that i wrote a book this that's a
pamphlet so
um so there you go and you know you've
been i've been listening to you make fun
of that one for years and since you
wrote it and i always thought oh come on
john it's a legitimate piece of work it
is because it is a legitimate piece of
work and then then i do one that's even
thinner so there you go what's going to
be great is at the end of the year when
we when we do the the end of the year
sales numbers and
we're going to tell you the momentum
theorem crushed baby steps millionaires
now i'm going to be best yeah
i don't want to hear that at all oh my
gosh
all right it is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires joe is next on the
line in st louis joe what's your net
worth
uh 2 million good for you give me a
little breakdown on that uh by category
so one and a half million is in my 401k
in mutual funds i have some stock grants
and the rest 500k is in house and cars
okay perfect that was easy all right how
old are you i am 55. cool how much of
this did you inherit
zero
okay what was your best household income
working year and your worst household
income working year
i started out making 17-5
and
funny thing is i i called you 30 years
ago no way
yes i would lived in nashville tennessee
called you 30 years ago i was a pretty
typical college student got out of
college got married
bought a brand new car got credit card
debt and uh called you
and uh you gave me great advice yeah i
was probably nicer than
nah yeah you were nice but you were
stern okay you told me to get on a
budget uh
put money away in my emergency fund
and then start stuffing money and
maximizing my 401k and that's what i did
and 30 years later i i'll tell you dave
i it hasn't been a perfect ride but i i
got here
made mistakes along the way but every
time i made mistakes i got right back
into the program and got back to my
budget got back to everything that you
teach
wow i'm proud of you very cool dude well
done 30 years and you're worth a couple
million dollars very good so what's been
your career
i majored in computer science in college
and so i've been in technology uh ever
since okay what was your what was your
highest income earning year
um probably last year and
with um salary and and stock option our
stock grants it was about 250. good for
you well done not bad from 17.5 yeah
very cool absolutely okay if you're
going to look back
and you're talking to joe like i did 30
years ago
the 30 year the 30 year old 30 year ago
version of joe
25 years old
uh what would you tell him you attribute
the 2 million dollars to how do you get
there what what should he do what you
say i did this and it worked
so i would say you know i got debt-free
and i stayed debt-free um and then when
i slipped i got back
and i i i worked hard to get debt free
um and then maximizing my 401k um i'm
i'll tell you i married the right person
i married a beautiful intelligent
financially responsible christian wife
uh with five wonderful kids two of which
are now on a budget just like you taught
me 30 years ago and
and uh in building up their emergency
fund and maximizing their
401ks um
you know the mistakes i made along the
way i didn't save enough for college as
you i have five kids
and i totally underestimated how much it
would be for college so i would
definitely focus there for my uh
if i started over 30 years ago
and i would have saved earlier and i
would have saved more yeah
wow well done joe proud of you man great
job very good job rick is in wilmington
north carolina rick what's your net
worth
dave my net worth is approximately 2.75
million good for you to go rick cool
give me a little breakdown on that by
category
uh we have about 1.6 in two homes we own
we have uh
1.3 in
mutual funds stock accounts and then the
balance is in 401k and ira
okay a little cash on the side too about
100 000 in cash gotcha okay wow good for
you okay
thanks very good how old are you
67 years good and how much of this 2.75
did you inherit
none
zero i did i will caveat that my dad did
leave me 20 000 when he passed away
which we used to retire debt we had some
credit card debt at the time
and uh so we we've been debt-free other
than mortgage and cars since that time
but it's safe to say you're not a
millionaire because of inherited money
yeah
okay no it's not
i love my dad and it gave me a great
step forward but not not the reason
we're here sure
and your range of income best year and
worst year
uh
probably my worst years were you know 20
25 000 back in the 80s
my best year was 2020 when i made 2.2
million
that's helpful okay
what was your career
i work in uh security internet security
authentication authorization uh and i
caught a ride on a fast-moving rocket
ship and did quite well yeah that sounds
like it congratulations well done so i
assume your degree is in technology
i my degree is in the school of hard
knocks dave i went to uh college several
times but never got a degree in learned
technology i went to technical school to
learn technology because that's where
the money was in the 90s when i was
broken and hurting so you tech students
he doesn't have a four-year degree in
information systems he has certs from
going to school just made 2.2 million
just just letting everybody know how
this works okay
wow good job rick well done sir this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i don't know whether it was in the name
of victimology
or whether it was in the name of whining
or whether it was in the name of evil
political intent whether it was in the
name of the spread of communism but
somewhere
out there for whatever reason whatever
the motivation was
began this narrative
that is absolutely false
about where wealth comes from
it's a lie
all rich people have inherited their
money
now of course the underlying statement
that that says is that if you don't have
a rich uncle you're screwed
so no need to work hard no need to save
your money no need to invest because the
real method of building wealth is to
inherit money and so the system is
broken and so the rich people should
have all the money taken away from them
and given to the common people is that
it's a very communistic socialistic
underlying message
and the the interesting thing is it's
based on an
absolute statistical lie
we did the largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america
my friend tom stanley who passed away a
few years ago his daughter sarah still
does research for the book the
millionaire next door it came out in
1992
30 years ago
30 years ago
and
you know
and he did a study of 750 millionaires
and he was always criticized for the
sample size john and i have done enough
research and and have studied enough
research
bodies of research to know that 750 is
statistically significant but most
people in the press don't understand
that and people with a political agenda
go well you didn't study real
millionaires he just picked out the 750
you wanted and had confirmation bias and
it just wasn't true it was a solid study
but
we decided to do a similar study 30
years later
and we said hey
we know 750 is statistically significant
but let's do 10 fold let's do 7 500 just
to shut up the whiners
and we got carried away we ended up
studying over 10 000 millionaires here's
what we found 79
of america's millionaires the largest
study ever done airtight research no
confirmation bias research company
looking over our shoulder to make sure
it's right because i knew some of you
would [ __ ] moan and whine when i did it
and so
when we we knew you were going to be out
there we knew you weren't going to like
what we found because we know these
people we worked with them every day and
we knew who they were
and so anyway what ended up happening
was 79 inherited precisely zero
five percent did inherit money
but it was an insignificant amount
like twenty thousand bucks five thousand
bucks something like that which is not
enough mathematically to make you a
millionaire unless you start when you're
one years old and then it still won't
make you a millionaire
so
they didn't inherit enough to become
millionaires or another five percent did
inherit substantial money like a 250 000
inheritance or something like that after
they were already millionaires and so of
course that did not make them
millionaires so 79-0 79 small 79 large
after
or
79
0 5
were small five percent large but after
that's 10 plus 79 it's 89 that's nine
out of 10 of america's millionaires
did not become millionaires because of
an inheritance okay let me let me let me
uh
push on the next question then
so i'm sitting in my sociology class and
i hear that and i say okay so they
didn't get money but they all were able
to pay cash for brain surgery med school
for all these brain surgeons that all
became millionaires
no they actually didn't um
one-third of them 33 percent of them
never made over a hundred thousand
dollars
[Music]
and the top the top five professions
were engineer accountant teacher
uh manager
and lawyer doctors didn't even make the
top five
of the professions that we studied and i
was being sarcastic about that but in
the day
this idea that you've
become a millionaire you've got to make
a million dollars a year yeah well you
get you've got privilege right you know
you got
class privilege or you've got
uh race privilege education privilege
yeah yeah that said you you got a head
start yeah we studied the people we
found they had all kinds of different
starting lines yeah the only thing is
they all had the same finish line yep
and all race demographics all age
demographics all regional demographics
we couldn't find anything that said if
you live in this area
or if you are this color you are more
likely
now we did find
whites were more likely statistically
on average
but
not to where you you could say you know
race is a sufficient blocker those the
numbers weren't there
uh plenty of african americans plenty of
asians plenty of latinos becoming
millionaires it was really not that was
not the correlating thing the
correlating thing was what they did that
they found a system a process and they
followed it so and they believed they
could do it help me with this because
i've led organizations that led teams
i want to communicate to the people that
worked for me that they can do anything
because that helps the system
what is the political motivation
behind trying to convince people that
you are powerless
i don't understand that as a leader it
doesn't make it doesn't compute for me
because then i get a team that well if
you're dependent on the government for
your answers then you're waiting on them
to give you something and the ones that
give you something the ones you vote for
you know and so and that's why we just
tell people all the time you know what
happens in your house is whole so much
more important than what happens in the
white house
and so if you're waiting on the
alzheimer's patron in charge to get you
out of this you're screwed i just i
don't i hate that i hate that idea that
we're just telling generations of people
you can't make it that's why i did this
that's why because it it the hope
stealers are out there yeah they're
stealing people's hope and it you know
it made me angry yeah and i also was
running into these baby steps
millionaires everywhere like that guy
that called earlier he said you know i
started 30 years ago i called you and
you told me get rid of my car and get on
a budget
and here i am 30 years later with 2
million net worth i'm a baby step
smiling i follow the baby steps and oh
by the way my kids are on the same track
now so it's a generational change you
know or sanji reminds me of the
international students to work with it
came and just their eyes would light up
and say look at all the opportunity what
are you doing work hard we have to go go
go i had a kid from uh uh czechoslovakia
that worked here years ago it just
killed me so funny
uh he he was he was working on his mba
and he quit to go to college in another
location
and he emailed me about three weeks
later and he goes i needed money for my
tuition i couldn't figure out what to do
he said i went to a garage sale and it
was a nike shoe sales guy
and he had all the samples and he said i
bought an entire garage
of shoes
for like 200 bucks
and he sold us he said i just finished
selling them all on ebay for thirty four
thousand dollars good grief i'm going to
college what a country and he like what
a country you know like a classic line
you know because he's like there's so
much abundance here and everybody's
standing around and he he went to a
garage sale made one transaction versus
and then another 100 transactions on
ebay
and goes to college what a country
you're right you know but instead we
tell people oh no you got to wait on
biden bucks
because you're you know you're just
screwed if you know the government's
going to get you out and that's really
the underlying evil of people stealing
people's hope yeah and that's why we do
the baby steps empowering theme hour you
don't have to be famous you don't have
to be an athlete you don't have to be a
rock star less than one percent
of millionaires have recognizable
household names
and you don't have to be a high gpa
uh we we find the average gpa is right
slightly above three and uh now we don't
find 1.5
i mean you do have to have some gray
matter to be able to pull this off you
gotta have a brain
okay
dumb doesn't work all right so but uh
but also you don't have to be a 4.2 you
know and i'm not i'm not a you know i i
graduated thank you lottie okay so
that's
you know that's that's what you're after
here so
you know the thing is you just you say
okay what do i attribute this to and the
first two said i'm debt free my 401 k
live on less than i make unified with my
spouse the stuff we teach around here
every day and that's the baby steps
millionaires and that's what these
people are then and they're every age
every location
and the moral of the story is you can do
it too
and we're going to talk to a couple more
before we wrap this particular hour up
so don't you dare go anywhere
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today joshua 1 8 keep this
book of the law always on your lips
meditate on it day and night so that you
may be careful to do everything written
in it
then you will be prosperous and
successful
joe dimaggio said a person always do it
doing his or her best becomes a natural
leader
just by example it's a baby steps
millionaire theme hour roger and kim are
with us in columbus ohio hey guys what's
your net worth
we're right around two million dollars
dave cool give me a little breakdown on
that
we got 1.3 in 401ks we got 60k in roth
260
cash 350 000 paid for
house some company stock that's not best
for about 40k
and about 40k and paid for cars cool how
old are you guys
i am 59 i'm 47.
excellent how much of this money did you
inherit
uh we
inherited just about zero in the last
year my uh my dad gave me about 20k that
uh that came in from his uh estate so
that's about all we've got
cool what's been the range of your
working in time
income best
best year and worst year
we started out together at about 75k
fortunately kim is a high wage earner
and she's a 300 we're at 318k now
and the average would have been about
150k okay cool so what do you guys do
for a living
i work for a us-based apparel retailer
i'm the head of sustainability
okay and i'm an over-the-road business
to business sales rep
the head of sustainability
yeah what does that mean what do you do
i manage all of our social human rights
environmental energy and international
community giving programs oh okay wow a
big big company then okay
all right very cool all right so what
are your degrees in
my degree is in organizational
communication uh makes sense
and i was a history major way back when
got you okay all right cool so what do
you attribute the fact that you have two
million dollars at 59 and 47 too
well you know it's funny dave we have to
say thank you because what we did was uh
we
basically had nothing when we started
out and we went to your class around
2007 2008
and everything has grown from there
but it's been you know just about uh you
know
living living your life with uh
you know not spending more than you make
taking care and being content with what
you have
and that's where we
following the baby steps
okay cool very cool it sounds like you
guys were on the same page
yeah that was helpful and that we're not
big spenders we're pretty content in
life and we didn't want to carry debt
and we want to retire early so we had a
plan yeah that you both were in
agreement on being on the same page yeah
that's a big deal
big deal yes what advice would you give
to these kids go ahead i'm sorry
no i'm just saying we wanted to be out
of debt before we put our kids through
college so they wouldn't have any debt
coming out of college very good what
advice would you give to the younger
version of you
um i always say stay positive um my life
motto has always been work hard be true
and good things will happen to you and
that god is always good
[Music]
amen well done good job you guys
congratulations thank you very much for
sharing your story very good stuff david
is in dallas david what's your net worth
uh hey there dave um my net worth is
about 1.3 to 1.4 depending on the on the
day these days cool that's the way it
works yeah all right give me a little
breakdown on that by category
uh yeah i have about
900k in
real estate with 300k in debt against
that so neta 600.
i have about a half a million in 401k
retirement accounts
um and then i have around two to three k
and like cash and other like liquid type
investments
in crypto
i'm 34 years old okay how much did you
say was in crypto
i have about 100k sitting there um i
definitely didn't buy it for that but
it's there now so okay
we bought it for less i hope
okay oh yeah certainly yeah it's gone in
half so yeah okay uh all right so how
much of this did you inherit
uh none of it
okay thankfully all right and been
what's been your working income your
best year working income and worst year
best and work uh best years probably
nowadays i make between probably
200 to 300 a year depending on the year
and bonuses and things like that and
then my worst year was probably
right out of college i made about 45k a
year cool what do you do for a living
uh i work in accounting and then i have
a few side hustles with rental income
and uh
i sell some things online for ebay uh do
like retail arbitrage type stuff little
hobbies like that so you've got a degree
in accounting i assume
correct yeah okay what was your gpa
uh around 3.8 okay but pretty sure the
guy who writes my checks is less so
whoa i don't know if i can recover from
that one uh so what are you uh they're
doing better than you hey just scroll
look at your bank balance compared to
mine and you'll be just fine you did
this uh
you did this by 34
very young millionaire what do you
attribute that
to um just consistent saving i think
when you look at like your 401k in
retirement accounts
uh you can put 6000 a year into an ira
and you can put 19 000 a year into
a 401k and so if you just did that for
10 years you'd have a quarter of a
million dollars basically stacked up um
so but you have to do it every year i
think is the trick so just
consistency and making sure that you pay
yourself first
would be my best advice i suppose
okay very good
you think it can still be done today
uh yeah it can not that it's not
difficult i think there's a lot of
things that you see now for young people
that are challenges that
that even i didn't have uh as a younger
person
but that doesn't mean they're not
navigable i mean there were new things
for me as a young person that weren't
around for my parents and i'm sure there
were things for them that weren't around
for their parents
so there's always a way but i think it's
just uh having the determination and
will to to find it and then to also
listen to others and learn and it's not
always fun either um there are certainly
sacrifices that have to be made and
decisions that have to be made that are
difficult but
uh what have you given have you uh have
you given up your quality of life at 34
in order to get here
no no certainly not um and actually even
now like i'm able to enjoy my life a lot
more with the with the decisions that
i'm able to make and i feel like the
they have a lot more tools in my toolbox
at this point
that uh some of my friends who who maybe
didn't make the same decisions or you
know just chose other paths maybe don't
have and i feel really really lucky and
blessed to have that
i thank my my past self for making the
decisions that i did to
set me up for where i am now um
and so even now as i make decisions as
in my 30s i always have one foot kind of
in the next the next decade you know
like what would what would 40 year old
me be happy that 30 year old me does
yeah and what's third made me happy that
20 year old me does what a great way to
live man that's beautiful well thought
well thought out
good job david proud of you man proud of
you that's that i mean that that to me
is the key dave is to ask yourself right
now
this time next week what choices will i
be glad i made when it comes to eating
and exercising and marriage
and then next year and then 10 years
from now and 25 like what can i do right
now to sow those seeds yeah it's uh the
old henry cloud thing what's your
desired future yeah and
what has to be true
to get to that desired future yeah
starting now and right now and you know
in the desired future can be friday
um but the longer your planning window
the more vision you have
the higher quality your life is going to
be
so you have a better vision a long term
vision for your marriage a long-term
vision for your kids long-term vision if
you have a long-term vision for your
kids you're not raising great kids
you're raising kids to become great
adults as andy anders says it changes
the way you do everything that's right
when you start looking out past the cusp
it's good stuff dr john dolone good show
james and austin and ben and zach and
andrew and kelly great work i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you